Sean what is the latest that we're able
to to know for certain is happening on
the ground it's always difficult to know
for certain when it's only we're picking
up Russian reports of this so we can
advise what the Russian reports we've
been waiting for this spring offensive
for some time where the Russian defense
Ministry has said it started
um they claim they've thwarted a
large-scale attack in the donets region
just where the arrows are popping in
there
um claim that about 250 ukrainians were
killed a load of tanks were destroyed
and armored personnel carriers again in
zapparicha just a bit further over this
side
um the claim that Ukraine's have
advanced about 400 meters but the
Russians have held them back
um but actually we understand that the
fighting is continuing today there so
that's uh ongoing the Russians have also
provided video footage but as ever with
the Russian video footage it's
incredibly grainy it's very difficult in
the studio to pick out anything
hopefully the viewers will pick out a
little bit more but it's very difficult
to work out exactly where it is what the
vehicles are what time and date it's
very difficult to verify uh at all
what's got gone on um it is worth noting
that General grazimov the boss of
Russian army apparently has been
directing some of this heroic Russian
defense that looks very unlikely he
doesn't normally get involved and
actually that's almost certainly part of
the Russian army effort to rebuild its
credibility so we've got to take all of
these things with a little bit of a of a
pinch of salt
um it's also worth pointing out that the
first phase of these operations often
are very slow to take ground because of
course inevitably the Ukraine's bump
into the first line of the Russian
defenses is only once they've broken
through that that then you get a little
bit of momentum so we also comment about
uh evgeny precaution he's claimed that
Ukrainian forces have retaken burkivka
which is just a settlement just the
north of Bank moon this is particularly
important because the uh vulner group
lost a lot of people fighting to take
back moot Russian army looking at the
outskirts it looks likely that the
Ukrainian forces are gradually pushing
the Russian army back and there's been
reports the Russian army are running
away which of course and has described
this as disgraceful but it is worth
point
has his own agenda here he is boss of a
mercenary group they only make money if
they are employed somewhere he's in a
long-running feud with the Russian army
effectively vulden group we can do stuff
that the Russian army cannot with his
own agenda we've got to be really
careful to take what he says with a
pinch of salt what about Iran what Royal
have they played in helping Russia
prepare for this counter-offensive
Russia's been really short of long-range
missiles and particularly long-range
drones and since the start of the
conflict they've been importing the
Shaheed 136 drones from from Iran
literally in May May over 300 of these
were deployed against targets uh in in
Ukraine itself almost certainly in an
effort trying to swamp the defenses but
it looks likely that over 90 of these
were taken down by older air defense
systems and jamming by the ukrainians
it's worth pointing out the Ukraine's
also have multi-layered defenses which
include the Patriot missile system as
well it's unfortunately when they do
shoot them down obviously they've got a
50 kilogram Warhead in these can explode
cause damage fires on the ground but at
least they're not hitting their intended
targets uh the aim but it's also this is
just what not just a one-way traffic
it's also that Iran in return for
selling these it's managed to get Russia
to sell state-of-the-art Fighters su-35s
so this looks like it's not a one-off
it's a growing defense trade partnership
between Iran and Russia meanwhile
Belgium is asking Ukraine for answers is
over weapons used on Russian soil what
more do we know about that a lot of this
is about the cross-bordering cursions
we've been reporting around Belgrade
with lots of sort of pro Ukraine groups
going into Russia and on little raids
then coming out again tactically it's
not really significant strategically
it's causing Russia a bit of a headache
but the news is that some of the weapons
that have been seen on Russian soil
appear to be weapons that have been
given by the West to Ukraine that are
only to be used in the defense of
Ukraine and not to be used on Russian
soil there's things like tactical
vehicles that were provided by the US
and Poland and also rifles provided by
Belgium now Belgium has turned around
and say they're going to run an
investigation into this but they've been
very quick to point out that Belgium's
been exporting Small Arms light rifles
for decades and these go all around the
world and inevitably they get sold on so
it's not yet to be convinced about
there's actually proactively using I
think there'll be a lot more news here
if America or the West sees high-tech
weapons on Russian soil not seen that
yet